لا نملك الا نقول سبحان الله معنا الان من
غازي عنتاب مراسلنا منتصر ابو نبوت منتصر
اذا في ظل كل هذه الاخبار
القاسيه جدا والمؤلمه جدا دائما هناك يعني
نقاط ضوء وفي هذا الوقت المتاخر بعد حدوث
الزلزال ما زال هناك امل في الحصول ماذا
عن اهالي المفقودين الى اي حد هذا فعلا
مازال حاضرا في اذهانهم
يعني اهالي المفقودين بالطبع هم اكثر
اشخاص متمسكين بالامل لانهم لا يريدون ان
يسمعوا خبر سيء عن ابنائهم او ذويهم تحت
الانقاذ وفي الحقيقه بالرغم من خروج هذه
السيده اليوم في غازي عنتاب بعد مئه
وسبعين ساعه تقريبا لان الفرص يعني بدات
تكون اضعف او اقل لاننا دخلنا بسبعه ايام
وهذا امر يعني اصبح صعب وفرق الانقاذ
اكدوا لنا ذلك خلال متابعتنا معهم يعني
طوال الليل الماضي لكنهم لم يتوقفوا عن
البحث هم بالطبع يحاولون ويستمرون لانهم
متمسكون ايضا بالامل ومتمسكون ايضا بما
يصفه هنا الاتراك بالمعجزه عندما يخرج اي
شخص بعد وقت طويل تحت الانقاذ هذا على
صعيد البحث الذي لا زال مستمرا في مدينه
غازي عنتاب في مدينه الاصلاحيه وفي مدينه
نورداغ هاتين مدينتين الاصلاحيه ونور ضاغط
يتبعان اداريا لولايه غازي عنتاب ايضا
السلطات المحليه هنا اعاده الطمانينه
للناس وتحاول ان تعيد الحياه الى المدينه
لكن هذا الامر قد لا يكون سهلا عليها لان
الناس هم في حقيقه خائفون ولذلك هم
ينتشرون في الشوارع وفي الساحات العامه
وفي كل مكان الحكومه او السلطات المحليه
اطلقت فرق هندسه
متخصصه لابني فحص الابنيه في جميع مدينه
غازي عنتاب وتحديد الاضرار وبناء عليها
قالت ان الاشخاص الذين لا تكون ابنيتهم
متضرره يمكنهم العوده الى منازلهم هذا ما
قالته الولايه واطلقت موقع الكترونيه
للتحقق من ذلك ان كان المواطن يدخل لهذا
الموقع البوابه الالكترونيه وتحديد عنوان
منزله ثم يظهر هذا البناء اذا ما كان
متضررا ام لا واذا كان ضرره خفيف قالت
الولايه انه بامكانه العوده الى منزله لكن
هذا لن يكون سهلا لان الاهالي في الحقيقه
خائفين ومذعورين من
المنطقه نحن الان في ميدان الديمقراطيه
احد اشهر الميادين في غازي عنتاب ومن خلف
هنا هذا يظهر مبنى الولايه شاهدنا قبل
قليل رصدنا فرقته قوم بتقييم الاضرار في
مبنى الولايه نفسه الذي تضرر اجزاء منه
وهناك تشققات في ايضا يحاولون من خلاله
تقييم هذه الاضرار
وفحصها من اجل الترميم والعوده الى الحياه
والعمل لكن بالقرب من هذا المبنى هو يعني
نحن نقف في حيث نقف هي ميدان الديمقراطيه
وهذا الميدان كما نشاهد قد نصبت فيه عدد
من الخيام للاهالي الذين يعني لا يرغبون
في العوده الى منازلهم في الوقت الحالي
هذا الميدان طوال الليل يكون فيه السيارات
كثيره فيها عوائل تنام في هذا المكان وهذه
ظاهره منذ يعني نحو يومين شاهدناها هناك
كثير من الاهالي ياتون بسياراتهم ليلا الى
هذا الميدان والى الميادين اخرى والى
الحدائق وينامون وفي الصباح يذهبون الى
منازلهم للاطمئنان عليها
وقضاء بعض الساعات وقضاء حاجياتهم
الاساسيه ثم يعودون في الليل الى هذه
الاماكن خصوصا الاشخاص الذين حضروا لحظه
الزلزال الاول الذي ضرب غازي عنتاب
والمنطقه قبل سبعه ايام ايضا خلال وقوفنا
الان كان هناك مروحيات في في اجواء مدينه
غازي عنتاب وهذه هي من المساعدات والاغاثه
التي يتم نقلها الى قرى يصعب الوصول اليها
تابع اداريه لولايه غازي عنتاب الولايه
تحدثت ان الجيش التركي قام بنقل المساعدات
الى نحو 500 قريه تعرضت وتضررت بسبب هذا
الزلزال ويصعب الوصول اليها لسببين اما ان
تكون طرقات قد تشققت جراء ذلك الزلزال او
ان الثلوج تغلق هذه الطرقات لانها في
النهايه هي طرق تؤدي الى قرى فتكون اقل
كفاءه من الطرق التي تؤدي الى او التي
تؤدي الى المدن الكبرى الطرق الرئيسيه كل
ذلك يعني تسعى من خلاله الولايه الى ان
تشعر المواطنين بالطمانينه ولذلك ايضا
ينتشر الجيش التركي في عدد من المواقع
ويقوم بالتجوال سواء في مدينه غازي عنتاب
او في مدينه اصلاحيه او في مدينه وذلك
لتامين المدينه من السرقات التي يعني تحدث
عنها الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
والاشخاص الذين استغلوا فرصه الفوضى التي
حدثت بعد الزلزال وقاموا باعمال يعني بعض
من اعمال السرقه ايضا الجيش التركي
شاهدناه يشارك في عمليات البحث والانقاذ
سواء كان في مدينه غازي عنتاب او في
الاصلاحيه او في نورداغ وهذه الاعمال يعني
كانت في في جهود دعم وتسهيل العمل على فرق
الانقاذ ومساعدتها لان المصاب كبير
بالنسبه لهذه المدينه هنالك اكثر من
19,000 قيمه نصبت في ولايه غازي عنتاب هذه
الخيام لا تكفي لكل سكان الولايه وهي ايضا
قد خصصت الاشخاص الذين تضررت منازلهم بالف
وايضا هدمت بابنيتهم لذلك خصصت لهم هذه
الخيام بالاضافه الى اكثر من الف منزل
متنقل الخيام والمنازل يمكن ان يرتفع لدها
وفقا لما قال وزير الاسكان عندما زار غازي
عنتاب لكننا نتحدث عن الاف العائلات نحن
نتحدث عن اشخاص بيوتهم قد لا تكون متضرره
او يوجد فيها تصدعات بسيطه لكنهم لا
يرغبون في العوده اليها على العموم اليوم
شاهدنا حركه للسيارات شهدنا بعض المحاليل
الجزائر التجاريه تفتح ابوابها وتعود الى
العمل هنالك روح بدات يعني
تنبض في هذه المدينه نوعا ما في محاوله
لتدارك الامر ويعني
يعني القضاء الحاجات الاساسيه بعد سبعه
ايام من من العطله ومن التوقف بعد ذلك
زلزال الذي يعني اثر وتسبب
بماساه كبيره حقيقه في غازي عنتاب والمدن
التركيه وحتى شمال سوريا
المصاب كبير جدا ولكن الحياه تسير كما قلت
شكرا جزيلا لك منتصر ابو نبوت